every couple of years make a sporting
events like the World Cup and the
Olympics give us a glimpse into the
outer bounds of human performance
surrounding that spectacle quite
literally is an entirely different
calculus the decision to even put on the
games in the first place once a highly
sought role hosting a mega event is now
an entirely different proposition one
that politicians governments Executives
and citizens are asking is it worth it
what is the change in tourism during the
games and after the games controlling
for other variables what is the change
in fiscal revenues what is the change in
employment what is the change in GDP and
so on we don't see these gains
materializing there's some big numbers
that go around for Cutters spending on
this tournament I'm worried that the
government will be surprised at how many
people leave after the event is all over
I can see why hosting the Olympics and
bidding on the Olympics is attractive
but it absolutely comes with enormous
long-term risks and costs
after years of controversy and criticism
Mega sporting events could be on the
cusp of a new more sustainable era when
it comes to organizing the games there
must be a debate and we've done a lot of
reforms over the last decades to make
sure that the games remain relevant but
will the changes be enough to convince
potential hosts
one City's example might offer a way
forward we have the ability to really
fit the games to our community as
opposed to have to fit the community to
the games
foreign
the first winter World Cup held in the
compact affluent state of Qatar has
drawn a massive number of people to the
country organizers are expecting some
1.2 million people will come to the
country over the course of this
month-long event so you're essentially
thinking roughly a 10 increase in
population
every night in the most busy parts of
the tournament
Cutter's also really interested in
developing a tourism economy they've
seen the success of Dubai and even
though this is a much more conservative
country they think that they can draw
people here for other major sporting
events for conferences just to visit on
stopovers to other places so they're
hoping that some of the new hotels and
new entertainment venues and the like
that they've built for the World Cup can
get used by the next generation of
tourists
authorities estimate that hosting the
World Cup could add as much as 17
billion dollars into its economy
but in order to get to that point the
country has spent a massive amount of
money over the past decade on
infrastructure including building an
entirely New City
there are various estimates of how much
exactly Qatar has spent in order to
prepare for this event
the stadiums are really just a small
fraction
[Music]
while costs for the 2022 World Cup are
reportedly the highest ever for a
sporting competition it's part of an
unsettling trend for what are known as
Mega events Mega means big other than
the day-to-day leagues the NBA the NFL
MLB NHL or the English Premier League
the day-to-day leagues where they have
every couple of days or if it's baseball
every single day they have a new game
that's standard economic issues but if
it's something where a lot of people are
coming from out of town and there's one
big event or there's one series of
events like the Olympics is 17 days or
the World Cup has traditionally been
around 28 days you're doing something
special that doesn't normally happen it
involves tens of thousands if not
millions of people then we call that a
mega event
the first International modern Olympics
in 1896 held in Athens was considered
the first sporting mega event the
largest competition ever held up to that
time
although initially limited to male
amateur competitors from only 14
countries the Olympics have expanded
significantly in size scope and
inclusivity since
one key tradition that has persisted for
the past Century is that the games
travel every four years
every two years we have the Olympic
Games and the Winter Olympic Games which
represent what the movement collectively
does and and bring the best of the
sporting world together
[Music]
at the Helm of the modern games is an
organization called the international
Olympic Committee made up of delegates
from participating Nations
the ioc is responsible for choosing host
cities and ensuring that the games are
run in accordance with ioc rules the
movement has evolved tremendously over
more than the a century it has gone
through many developments as sport in
the end reflects society and to remain
relevant this is a constant adaptation
for the first half century or so the
games were a relatively low budget
affair
but beginning in the 1960s the ioc and
local planning committees began to see
value in lucrative sponsorships and
global television rights
as the potential rewards grew so did the
scale of the events along with the cost
to build infrastructure to host them
those costs however are not fronted by
the ioc it's up to the host cities who
bid for a chance to reap the potential
Rewards
but is it worth it
somewhere between four and six billion
dollars of Revenue will get generated by
hosting the summer games in these days
on the expense side it's much much much
higher that's not a good Financial
balance
projected costs for an event on an
Olympic scale are expectedly high but
the real trouble cities can find
themselves facing is when projected
costs go substantially over budget often
forcing governments to absorb the
overruns
the University of Oxford in England has
done a number of studies on costs and
cost overruns and what they have found
is that since 1976 the average cost
overrun or the median cost overrun for
the summer games is 252 percent so that
means 3.52 times the initial bid the
whole point about these studies is to
constantly be aware that organizing an
event like this is not a given it's a
constant strive to make sure that that
the games when it comes to its economics
do balance
what drives costs so exceedingly over
budget for Mega events well it's partly
due to optimism bias in which planners
simply assume things will cost less than
they ultimately do promoters might even
intentionally distort initial
projections to help win over
stakeholders
and by the time the mega event rolls
around there's simply no other option
but to spend more
if the Olympic games are going to start
on July 20th of a particular year you
can't call up and say oh gee we need
another two weeks the Olympic Stadium
won't be ready on July 20th no that that
can't happen and so once you have that
kind of a very firm hard deadline in
place now the construction companies
know that this has to be top priority
and they have to start shifting workers
from other construction projects and
shifting materials over there and that
gives them an excuse to bid up the
prices still more so you have all of
these factors working together and all
of a sudden you're two or three or four
or five times higher than the initial
bid not surprisingly enthusiasm for
hosting the games has varied over the
years for a period the game seemed
cursed from tragic violence around the
1968 Mexico City and 1972 Munich Summer
Games to a debt-ridden financial
disaster in 1976 that Montreal spent the
next 30 years paying off
more recently enormous budget overruns
political controversies and viral scenes
of decaying stadiums in Athens Rio de
Janeiro and Beijing have led some
citizen activists to openly question the
environmental impacts political Optics
and cost-benefit ratio of Hosting
Boston is an absolutely beautiful city
it looks great in the summertime it
looks great when you envision that
helicopter or drone shot looking over a
brand new stadium with fireworks going
off in our gleaming Skyline in the
background and the Charles River on one
hand and Boston Harbor on the other it's
really an impressive and gorgeous place
it's also
on or in the most valuable time zone in
the world the East Coast time zone
has something like 40 or 50 percent of
all of the American television viewers
Boston beats out Los Angeles San
Francisco and D.C and will be the U.S
bid in a worldwide battle for the 2024
games the polling was very clear that at
first
residents of greater Boston supported
the Boston 2024 Olympic bid the idea of
the Olympics improving the public
transportation system in Massachusetts
we was always the most appealing and
enticing part but what became clear is
that over time the more people learned
about the implications of the bid the
risks and the costs that they got Beyond
those glossy images and saw what it
would really mean for their lives and
for the future of the state
that people support for the games
dropped dramatically we see that the bid
requires building the three most
expensive Olympic venues that every
Olympics since 1960 has gone over budget
we felt that there needed to be a real
debate about whether the Olympics was
the right thing for Massachusetts or not
and we saw that because of the power of
the people pushing the bid there were
going to be very few institutions that
would normally ask tough questions of
the bid that we're going to do that in
this case and so that opposition had to
come from the Grassroots and that's why
we formed no Boston Olympics
thank you
Boston 2024's original proposal was to
put beach volleyball here in Boston
Common not a place that has sand not a
place along the water and one of the
most historic public spaces and
important public spaces in the U.S this
is the original public park in North
America
Boston was the first major city to stand
up and say no to the summer 2024 games
but in the wake of our decision in
Boston other cities dropped out Rome
Italy had been talking about bidding a
new mayor was elected there who said she
had more important priorities than the
Olympics and so that bid died Hamburg
Germany actually had a public referendum
to bid on the 2024 games and voted that
down in November of 2015 Budapest
Hungary there was a Grassroots
opposition to the games there that
forced the question of the Olympics to
be on the ballot and eventually the
organizers of the games there decided
not to move forward with it
in 2017 left with a dwindling set of
potential hosts for the 2024 games the
international Olympic Committee made an
unprecedented move it awarded the two
remaining contenders at the same time
Paris for 2024 and Los Angeles for 2028
giving the ioc some extra breathing room
and a chance to focus on a series of
reforms you have to to listen to the
critics as well and and we've been in
contact with them and other opponents to
the games because this is our mission to
listen and to make sure that that their
analysis we we do understand why they
reach these conclusions and what we can
improve
in the late 1970s the ioc was in a
similarly desperate position facing
backlash after a series of blemished
events earlier in the decade sensing a
rare opportunity for leverage the city
of Los Angeles decided that it could
make the 1984 Olympics a success but on
its terms
what happened in 84 was good for Los
Angeles it turned out for some very
interesting reasons but it was a
disaster because the ioc had to give up
on many of its requirements the ISU
requires for instance that a host City
guarantee that it will carry out all of
the tasks in its contract and and take
full responsibility financially for any
costs that are involved in 1984 because
Los Angeles was the only city that was
bidding the ioc basically was on its
knees in front of the Los Angeles
committee saying please please do this
and so the Los Angeles committee
dictated terms and one of the terms was
we're not going to be responsible for
cost overruns by most accounts the 1984
Los Angeles Summer Games Were a
resounding success instead of saddling
taxpayers with a catastrophic loss the
games were actually profitable thanks to
a strategic corporate sponsorships and
manageable costs
because the metropolitan area already
had suitable stadiums venues and housing
very little new construction was needed
preventing the sort of surprise expenses
that had plagued earlier host cities
and now amid another challenging period
for the Olympics Los Angeles is again
trying to rewrite the narrative we like
to say that the la-84 games are actually
what gives us the ability to have such
great public support here in Los Angeles
for the games you can't walk around this
city and and not meet somebody who has a
positive memory of 1984 and that's
really the the starting place for us we
are a no build games and and sometimes
we like to say it's a part of our
radical reuse philosophy around
sustainability the fact is the best
venues are the ones you don't have to
build
right over my shoulder you can see uh
one of the the main pieces that will
actually be the secret sauce of of La
being able to host the Olympic Games and
that's UCLA we have UCLA and USC within
really a just about 10 to 12 miles of
each other and really that's the
beginning stages of infrastructure but
beyond that you know we really have just
an extraordinary number of venues here
in LA and in greater Southern California
whether it's three facilities three
stadiums that are over 75 000 seats
multiple Arenas different types of
facilities and so we're just tailor-made
to be able to actually host a mega
sporting event like the Olympics and the
Paralympics as for potential cost
overruns la-28 has a plan in mind
we actually are carrying a 10
contingency from day one in our budget
in terms of how and what it is that we
actually think about and so we're trying
to build against that contingency
I think it's incumbent upon all of us to
think about everything that we do and
think about it through the lens of
sustainability we'll have uh probably
just shy of a hundred thousand jobs that
will be a part of our journey over the
next six years and that's billions of
dollars of economic impact directly to
citizens of LA
beyond the raw cost benefit figures
there is another value to the Olympics
that is harder to measure for us it's
really about human Legacy and it starts
actually with the kids that we want to
be sitting in the stadiums thinking and
dreaming that they too can be an
Olympian or a paralympian as a part of
our Play La program which is our 160
million dollar investment into kids in
Los Angeles one of the the real
important parts of that is we've already
introduced adaptive Sports into the
rexham park program in the city of La
I'm optimistic about the 28 games for
the same reasons I think that they have
really excellent management of of the
organizing committee and they're Los
Angeles we've got a lot more stadiums
now than they had back in 1984 and
they've got more infrastructure
including public transportation that
they didn't have so I think it'll turn
out it'll turn out well
meanwhile at the other end of the
spectrum there were places where costs
simply aren't a major concern but this
path comes with its own set of problems
the person who really seems to have
wanted to host the World Cup more than
anyone else is
now known as the father Emir he was the
former ruler of Qatar and this was
really his desire not just to host you
know a massive football tournament he
knew that it would drive an enormous
amount of development in the country
that Qatar really needed to become a
kind of modern place
and that's exactly what happened in the
last decade alone Qatar has built more
roads bicycle paths and bridges than
during the entire previous half century
funded by a robust petroleum and natural
gas-based economy the government was
less concerned with short-term profit
and more interested in the long-term
benefits of future tourism Business
Development and Global prestige
for instance they've gone to Great
Lengths and no doubt expense to show off
cutting-edge engineering Feats such as
this Innovative Stadium design
constructed partly out of shipping
containers meant to be easily
deconstructed and transported elsewhere
but the attention the nation has
received has generally not been so
positive behind the scenes many more are
being exploited unpaid forced labor
badly treated it's very hard to give an
exact figure I would suspect it's
actually in the hundreds I think
hundreds of workers have died to make
this world cup possible
there was initially reports about the
deaths of workers in stadium projects
and other projects directly tied to the
World Cup this obviously set off an
enormous International outcry and
ultimately the government did start
making reforms in order to respond to
this so people were living in very
cramped unsafe unsanitary accommodations
they've set minimum standards on that
they also introduced a universal minimum
wage meaning it applies to people of all
nationalities
it's not much it's about 274 dollars a
month but it's something and in fact
it's the first Universal minimum wage
across the Gulf region generally
activists are not entirely happy with
the reforms that qadri government has
made they don't believe that some of
these reforms have gone far enough on
worker deaths for instance nobody really
had bothered to count for a long time
how many workplace deaths and injuries
you had across the country
activists are very concerned about what
happens after
everyone goes home I think these are
questions we don't know the answer to
qatar's hope is that in the long run
memories of compelling matches will
Outlast any lingering controversy
the 2022 World Cup story Echoes other
Mega events in recent years where strong
centralized governments have spent
lavishly to help build Global Prestige
only to find themselves marred by
controversy if you look for example at
the 2022 Winter Olympic bidding process
all of the democracies that were bidding
in that process actually dropped out
before the final bidding phase the only
two cities that were left were Beijing
China and Almighty Kazakhstan both
autocratic countries where there's no
democracy there's no input there's no
opportunity for residents to push back
against the extravagance of the games
Russia received a four-year ban for
doping from the world anti-doping agency
China has been criticized by some
countries and human rights groups over
what they say is abuse against uyghur
Muslims they're going to be under
increasing pressures from corporate
sponsors they're creating all sorts of
problems in terms of how the labor
forces is treated in terms of
environmental destruction and so on so
corporations are sort of pulling back uh
or they're saying well if you expect
this to stay around you've got to clean
this stuff up
mounting public concerns from citizens
cities and sponsors over the recent
Spate of controversial games have forced
organizing bodies like FIFA and the ioc
to pursue reforms one approach to
address the sustainability concern has
been to spread out make events over a
region or even a continent instead of
forcing a single City to take on the
burden
I think FIFA has an easier job only
because there are more places that have
the necessary venues and infrastructure
and and because of the very profound and
Lasting and pervasive popularity of
soccer they have more leeway I think
than the ioc so hopefully uh we'll see
some good changes there
in fact things are already looking
differently in the next World Cup which
will be spread out in 16 cities across
North America and rely mostly on
existing infrastructure
the World Cup is coming back to Boston
in 2026 and it never crossed our minds
to create uh no Boston World Cup group
because the costs are just going to be a
small fraction of what hosting the
Olympics would have been
as for the Olympics the ioc has spent
the past decade reflecting on its
complex Legacy and outlining Broad New
reforms aimed at Reinventing the games
for the sustainability conscious 21st
century
listen the most important was a decade
ago when we adopted motto that a city
does not adapt to the games but the
games adapt to a city then the second
thing which was important is we don't
build if it's not absolutely needed we
have a sustainability agenda that is
very appealing as well will be climate
positive as a rule from 2030 but already
Paris 2024 will be climate positive
which is a great objective to reach I
think everybody also is is recognizing
the efforts when it comes to
sustainability and the whole gender
economic social and environmental yes
it's more to deliver for the organizers
but for the better the successful
Olympics is one that first and foremost
brings back to the community what they
were expecting even the bidding process
once a fierce competition that often
encouraged the sort of wild promises
that led to financial pitfalls has been
reshaped it is a partnership now so we
have cities that come to us and say
listen what does it take if I want to
organize the games in 2040 and and the
big difference is that the ioc is not
judging anymore the quality of a given
value proposition it is contributing to
it
the plans for upcoming games Los Angeles
in 2028 Milan in 2030 and Brisbane in
2032 already seemed to be heeding the
warning signs of the past
so far at least
but some critics have proposed an even
more radical concept
what I would favor in the long run what
I think is most rational particularly in
these days of climate change and the
need to conserve resources and not waste
resources is we ought to have one city
that hosts the games permanently having
everyone agree on a single host City
might be a challenging diplomatic
problem regardless the institutional
reforms within the World Cup in the
Olympics demonstrate that Mega sporting
events can respond to the demands of an
ever-evolving planet and the days of
massive cost overruns and wasteful
infrastructure may be behind us
I think there are much more sensible
ways to proceed whether the world
decides to be sensible or not I think is
still an undecided question
[Music]